hey guys it's Monday the 13th of March
I'm Dan and Jessa's behind the camera
because she's a little bit sick today
let's see if I can do this this is
gamespot news I think straight out of
the gate I've had to take off my glasses
because the reflections from the lights
are messing with the camera but let's
just push right through Mass Effect
Andromeda has more dialogue than mass
effect two and three combined lead
writer math Walters told an audience at
PAX East that Andromeda has over 1,200
speaking characters compared to the 670
odd characters that spoke in Mass Effect
3 producer Michael gamble told pc gamer
they're not only are there more chatty
characters but the amount of things you
can talk two characters about is greatly
increased particularly concerning your
squadmates he explained we made sure the
squad was beefy and developed and that
you could do different things with them
and then that information would
basically carry through the
conversations Andromeda features and
drama to viability points which when
earned enable you to wake up colonists
so there's a whole bunch more people to
talk to right there next up rocket
League is getting a new free mode next
week develop a psionics announced that a
new match type called drop shot will
arrive next week on the twenty-second of
March inspired by volley ball drop shot
matches take place in a hexagonal arena
that's divided down the middle and
overlaid with a grid of smaller hexagons
instead of fixed goals players must
break through the floor of their
opponents half of the field by hitting
the ball downward when the ball is
struck by a member of either team it
changes color an orange ball breaks blue
floor and vice versa the heart of the
ball is hit the more damage to the
opponent floor it will cause the boost
meter now recharges automatically over
time to theoretically make the aerial
maneuvers required to score easier to
pull off I'm yet to be able to score a
goal on purpose in traditional rocket
League so I can't wait to accidentally
fly away from the ball while swearing
loudly at my TV drop shot will be
available in its own playlist as well as
private and exhibition matches and will
be free to all players finally a new
injustice to character has been
announced WWE wrestler Xavier woods
revealed on his YouTube channel that the
character firestorm would be joining the
roster now this one wouldn't have come
as a massive surprise to those of you
who saw nether realms Ed Boon teasing
the addition in December the gameplay
video shows off the fiery heroes ranged
finesse which includes throwing
fireballs and torpedoes you can check
out the full gameplay video in our story
on gamespot injustice to is due out for
ps4 and xbox one on May 16
that's if the game spot news for today I
am done please like and subscribe so we
can get just back here so I never ever
have to do this on my own again you can
head to gamespot to check out our battle
field one day shall not pass gameplay
and I guess that's it for me I'll see
you guys later